loki
hello mother having made you proud
please don't make this worse define
worse
enough i will speak to the prisoner
alone
i really don't see what all the fuss is
about do you not truly
feel the gravity of your crimes wherever
you go there is war
ruin and death
i went down to midgard to rule the
people of earth as a benevolent
god just like you
we are not gods we're born we live we
die
just as humans do
give will take 5 000 years all this
because
loki desires a throne it is my
birthright
your birthright what's today
as a child cast out
onto a frozen rock
if i had not taken you in you would not
be here now to hate me
if i'm for the accident for mercy's sake
just
swing it it's not that i don't love our
little talks it's just
i don't love them friega is the only
reason you're still alive and you will
never see her again
you'll spend the rest of your days in
the dungeons
and what a thor you'll make that witless
earth king while i rot in chains
though must strive to undo the damage
you have done
he will bring order to the nine realms
and then yes
he will be king
you